hello everybody
whoo
how many episodes is this gill dude i
think we're over 320. my god what a
voyage
and you know we don't get people back
here often you know no sometimes people
are one and done yikes they're harsh
if you're listening right now and you
did our podcast one time you'll come
back you're coming you're coming right
so i don't want to
feel let's not do it
but this um young talent that we have
can i say that sure i love that pretty
good huh yeah
did it make you feel good yeah okay i
did i does yes this young fresh talent
thank you with a new voice
dynamicism dynam dynamic wow right she
um
i think when she did our podcast before
we did it in the apartment yes yeah it
was before
crazy rich asians it was before right
this is before the gigantic wave that
she's gonna mean surfing on right it was
a while ago yeah right
and this is what
you don't realize this
nora
i might get emotional
no don't bobby don't no
don't what you don't realize is
the honor
because you made it
big
and you came back to the roots
to help us out
and that's how i'm seeing this event
okay all right yeah so god damn it
call me montgomery okay montgomery
thank you i love you brother you know
what else another brother can i say
something else brother
during my birthday party
okay
when i saw you at what's his name
dumbfoundead
you said you loved him before he just
said you loved him you literally said he
was your favorite person give him
everything
i can't keep not in public
[Laughter]
but um
you know when i went to a show and i saw
you there um
you said a couple of i was really
depressed
i came back in the party i felt good
about that but in general i was
depressed and you said some real nice
things to me and i really appreciate you
brought some
interesting people to the show you did
too you did too you who did i bring gina
grisham junior gershon
i think she would if if if you let her
she might do love to you she loves you
that much i love gina gershon i mean i
grew up watching her movies like crazy
me too yeah i'm a huge fan of hers huge
fan so talented don't you love it when
you
meet somebody that you were a fan of
and they're [ __ ] cool yeah they meet
your expectation like like meet your
heroes you know what i mean yeah me
you're one of those
what yeah you're a hero that one me it
exceeds if not me tell me more
yeah no
yeah
yeah
yeah all right it succeeds it's nice
but i don't like okay i brought gina
grisham but then you also you borrow out
be like benedict you know like he's the
our he's one of our maids
he's one of our main superheroes yeah
yeah right yes you didn't bring you
didn't bring shang chi did you
no
was not there that night no oh i want to
meet sanchi yeah i'm sure he'd love to
meet you is it good powerful you guys
actually met
at my thanksgiving what